come ti chiami da dove vieni di dove sei
chi sei sarete d'accordo con me sul
fatto che questo siena domande semplici
niente di che si chiedono a chiunque
ogni giorno in teoria anche erano
risposte dovrebbero essere altrettanto
semplici proviamo
iniziamo dal nome il mio si scrive così
questo in cigo o in alfabeto latino in
italiano si legge e milica ma in realtà
io mi chiamo così io sono milita in
italiano il mio nome non ha nessun
significato ma se qualcuno mi facesse
una piccola domanda ulteriore su cosa
voglia dire il mio nome io dovrei
spiegare tutto questo quindi anche per
dirvi come mi chiamo mi servono tre site
ma da dove sono da dove vengo oppure di
dove sono oppure ancora chi sono e qui
delle cose diventano proprio complicate
potrei rispondervi con una parola sola
dipende dipende da tante cose ma come fa
uno a non saper dire da dove il chi è
potete farmi vedere farmi mostrare
qualche mio documento di identificarmi
con così almeno le cose si chiariscono e
riuscita a sapere tutto
invece no non è così
vi posso dire che su questi documenti si
legge poco quasi nulla su di me ok io
potrei vorrei fare vedere il mio
passaporto dove accanto al mio nome
cognome data di nascita tre reti il nome
della città in cui sono nata
ma da nessuna parte non troverete le
informazioni che
in quella città non ci sono mai stata
più troverete un documento rilasciato
dal governo dal governo della repubblica
di serbia ma nessuno vi dirà che quando
sono nata io la repubblica serbia non
esistevano i confini odierni invece
faceva parte di un gran bel paese è
chiamato jugoslavia che solo pochi mesi
dopo la mia nascita si è evoluto in un
modo molto tragico nel mio passaporto da
nessuna parte scritto che i miei
genitori entrambi servi provengono
territorio che oggi appartiene al kosovo
in cui anni 90 si è combattuto il mio
legame in corcorso io potrei mostrarvi
solo se vi faccio vedere il vecchio
ormai scaduto da tanto tempo passaporto
da mia madre dove la mia foto da bambina
si trova accanto alla sua assieme all
indirizzo della nostra casa di famiglia
per in corso l'indirizzo della casa in
cui noi non siamo potuti rientrare mai
dopo la guerra perché la guerra
l'abbiamo perso noi l'hanno vinta loro
gli altri da nessuna parte
nei miei documenti e scritto che sono
madre lingua serba ma anche madre lingua
russa che sono cresciuta in russia che
la cultura russa facendo proprio mia e
che la neve e il ghiaccio me piace non
mille volte di più che qualsiasi in mare
e spiace che a mosca
io mi sono sempre sentita a casa ma non
è casa mia non è stata mai io non sono
russa non ce l'ho nessun documento
d'identità rilasciato dal governo russo
mi hanno detto mille volte ricordati il
sentimento di appartenenza non c'entra
nulla con i documenti d'identità
in questo punto se qualcuno fosse ancora
curiosa che qualsiasi altro documento
che ho avuto in questi anni potrei
dimostrare il mio diploma del liceo in
cui guarda caso un altro paese un paese
giovanissimo che esiste da 13 anni il
montenegro ma su questo diploma non
iscritto che io ci ho vissuto per dieci
anni e nessuno mi crederà che anche oggi
quando vado a trovare mio padre della
nuova casa di famiglia dove ci sono
ancora tutti i miei libri e la mia
vecchia stanza e ogni volta devo pagare
una tassa di soggiorno come tutti gli
altri turisti stranieri perché io non ho
nessun documento rilasciato dallo
governo montenegrino
allora adesso è riuscito un po di capire
perché io mi sono trovato sempre in
difficoltà a trovare delle risposte a
queste domande così semplici
quando ne aveva 19 anni mi sono
trasferita a vero grado capitale della
serbia
al di là in questura hanno visto il nome
della città in cui sono nata è
automaticamente mi hanno rilasciato la
mia prima carta d'identità
in questo momento nessuno mi ha fatto
una domanda ti senti a casa o no
l'indirizzo belgrado ma io ci sono
andata per trovare delle risposte
essendo iscritto all'università per
studiare antropologia sociale quella
senza un balistica bellissimo che tratta
i temi collegati con identità collettive
religioni etnie nazionalismi
cittadinanze e oggi da antropologa vi
devo dire che non ce l'ha fatta ma son
trovato
delle risposte semplici ma mi si è
aperto un mondo e mi si sono poste mille
altre domande
ormai in questo punto avete proprio
capito che trovarmi nelle situazioni
inspiegabili è la mia specialità ad ogni
caso da due anni ne ho un altro
documento tranquilli scader pro loco o
un permesso di soggiorno italiano in
toscana
l'indirizzo assegnato è località rondine
1 arezzo
ecco ecco dove sto da due anni è un
borgo medievale un pò isolato accanto a
una riserva naturale non è che ci vivo
da sola facendo rapunzel anche se non mi
dispiacerebbe ma come tanti posticini in
toscana sospesi in tempo sembra proprio
un posto da favola e lo è per sicuro che
lo è lei perché in questo borgo ha sede
un associazione straordinaria
si chiama rondine cittadella della pace
e questa associazione già da 20 anni
raccoglie delle persone che come me
hanno tante domande delle persone che
non hanno smesso a cercare delle
risposte e che non hanno smesso di
impegnarsi per il mondo un po più giusto
noi a rondine siamo una banda folle una
trentina dei giovani che non si lasciano
ingannare dal fatto che l'identità sia
una cosa fissa è sacra non negoziabile
niente di più di quello che mostrino i
meritati e nei grafici tutti quanti
abbiamo dei passaporti rilasciati dei
governi attuali o precedenti che hanno
fatto la scelta
di risolvere i conflitti loro con gli
altri stati e popoli san donà veramente
le guerre rendendo in questo modo le
nostre storie di chi siamo
così complesse e mai favolose quindi
tutti proveniamo dei contesti di
conflitto e post conflitto a rondine
cittadella della pace facciamo un
percorso ben particolare oltre a fare un
master universitario e formarsi come
risolve come trasformare i conflitti in
modo creativo noi impariamo come si
creano spazi e lo spazio è sicuro dove
le storie de titta si incontrano
raccontano e ripensano noi dopo due anni
certo che diventiamo un gruppo di amici
per tutto il mondo
noi sempre rimaniamo un gruppo formato
dalle coppie di nemici perché tutti
quanti siamo arrivati a rondine ha
cercate delle risposte attraverso il
contro del altro il proprio altro il
proprio nemico è quello che stiamo
provando a fare che lo facciamo non
siamo proprio proprio riusciamo e
mettersi in dialogo con l'altro mettersi
in dialogo col nemico e cosa vuol dire
mettersi in dialogo con nemico non parlo
che non vuol dire andare raccontare la
propria storia del passato e conflitto
il classico modo dove 1 è vittima è
l'altro è tutta la colpa viene scaricata
l'altro dove uno racconta la storia
venne un punto di ca starsi si libera e
va via
e non è questo il dialogo il dialogo
vuol dire fare fatica a prendersi
tempo e tanta pazienza per farsi piccoli
non farsi grandi è facile farsi grandi
ma farsi piccolomini modo tale per
liberare uno spazio all'altro e riuscire
ad avere pazienza per sentire la voce
dell'altro riuscire a sentire la sua
storia con tutte le sfumature che ci
sono solo in questo momento avviene la
conoscenza che dietro la bandiera dietro
il passaporto
c'è una personalità c'è una persona
c'è un umano perché se uno non prendi il
tempo e non si ferma ad ascoltare
l'altra parte non riuscirà mai a capire
delle tute complessità che ci sono
facendo tutto questo percorso
impariamo come uno riesce a dare fiducia
a l'altro a dare rispetto all'altro dal
rispetto vuol dire di non permettersi
mai di penalizzare le persone di loro
storie di non permettersi mai di ridurli
in quanto scritto nei loro documenti di
non chiudere gli occhi
lì non tapparsi le orecchie davanti alle
loro complessità e tutte le sfide che
hanno superato altra volta di nuovo io
mi sento a casa un'altra volta non sono
a casa ma stavolta mi sento a casa
perché mi sento libera a continuare a
cercare delle risposte ma nello stesso
tempo ho capito grazie a questi ragazzi
e loro storie che cercare delle risposte
risposte semplici e una strada sbagliata
vivere e pensare in modo semplice e un
modo sbagliato di risolvere le cose se
noi lo facciamo togliamo tutto questo
tutte le ricchezze che avevo acquisito
durante
tutto è travagliato sviluppo delle
nostre società
mi sento a casa perché accanto delle
persone con le loro storie
altrettanto complesse ci siano delle
persone che parlano russo ma il loro
popolo ha fatto le guerre contro i russi
le persone che parlano arabo mano un
passaporto israeliano persone che si
sentono armeni ma non ce l'hanno nessun
passaporto a mostrarlo persone che non
hanno dei confini per loro paesi ma non
si lasci non limitare del questo e
soprattutto le persone che sul fronte di
andare fino in fondo a trovare altro e
trovando e l'altro a trovare se stessa e
completare la propria storia
siamo una trentina e parliamo tante
lingue arabo ebreo almeno azerbagian
turco pozzetto ingusceto vanvera
bosniaco e così via
tante lingue ma andiamo d'accordo sul
fatto che tutto è molto complesso per
concludere ore
vorrei darvi un consiglio così da
semplificare la vostra vita nel futuro
invece di chiedere uno da dove viene e
dove sei
chi sei provate a sostituire la domanda
con quale lingue conosci
sarà un bel punto di partenza forse la
persona vi racconterò una storia che vi
aiuterà a scoprire voi stessi grazie
[Applauso]